we talked about your process for
rewriting let's talk about rewriting
your own project or a project that
you're initially hired to write not
someone else's first yes so what's your
process on that you open up your
computer you sit down you're not really
looking at prior pages before that time
I'm assuming rewriting as you mean I've
turned in a draft and they give me notes
yeah yeah and they say okay we like this
but here's some notes and then you're
going back over from pretty much page
one
sure last month we just went through
that and we'll probably go that through
again next month because I just turned
in something but last month the movie
that's shooting now I did rewrites the
first draft was pretty solid the second
draft a few sequences changed because of
particular things and so there's always
a list of notes specific of what needs
to be changed and what's not quite
working and needs to be finessed and
many things are sometimes technical
without any in particulars but how a
sequence is done is you know it's always
objects well how would that person get
that thing you know and in my mind I
write it but then there's the directors
mind who has to really shoot the film
and so that doesn't come into play till
the director comes on board and so then
the notes come in from the producer and
then maybe let's say another producer
who hasn't chimed in yet and then the
director and then they say okay and the
director is looking at it hopefully
about how can I shoot this film with the
money that I have and your mind but I've
never been at the locations so then a
lot of the notes changed well we can
only get this kind of place we need a
tweet for that and you go okay and those
are you know those are great you know or
don't have them have this thing have
them do you know being vague but you
know objects guns whatever you know
things in the script so you go through
with almost a checklist and you go and
make the fixes and hopefully like I said
with a solid treatment it shouldn't be
like the house of cards
you know implodes because that's not the
place to be in development when you're
like oh my gosh I've got to rewrite like
this whole thing you know it's still
solid
a B and C still happens but you get in
you start to you know and then and
there's there is a sequence that changed
by its own nature and I agree with
totally with the changes because it's
much you'll see a lot of nobody sets out
to make a bad movie and the changes are
not personal they're like oh we thought
of it and it's terrible somebody had to
think of it somebody had to write it
down somebody had to create it and then
comes the realities of shooting a movie
and so you know my job at that point is
to help them make the movie my job is to
help the producer director's job make
the film I'm not standing in their way
whatever needs to be changed it's
changed because now we're now we're
moving through development to a reality
face not this fantasy of like Oh at
least you know motivations have to track
if they don't they say this is kind of
weird with that character do this maybe
the other would flip or you were saying
about the strong you know keeping in
mind the protagonist well you gave that
to this other character she should be
doing this you're like oh yeah you're
right and it's just an easy fix because
the character then now is driving the
story and it's happening to them rather
not pushing it off to co-star or
something you know and it's very
obviously methodical but it is kind of
methodical because you know after doing
this for so long that it's like this is
what needs to be done and double
checking me going back through looking
at all that you know putting on revision
mode so they can you know see with the
you know so everybody's on the same page
and then they get it and and the nicest
thing is to hear even you know do a
quick polish let's say a couple day
polish which is you know fixing little
things is that the producer or director
comes back and says that was great job
you know still I still get happy you
know I'm still happy about hearing that
somebody says because they don't have to
say good job you know your job is you
know you got paid but great job and on
time because if you had taken a week
that would push you know I mean they're
already scouting locations they're doing
things I don't want to hold up that I
want to get this turned around as fast
as I can also to get
MyPlate to open up for other work you
understand so you want to be the team
player as I say an ultimate collaborator
at all steps in the way and know your
and know your place in the bigger
picture and so when I go to the set if
I'm not working on the set I'm a guest
you know I'm there it's nice I've been
on sets that I worked writing and you
know have also been on sets as a guest
where the director returned to me and he
knew like my first spec how long it took
to get it made and he would turn to me
and say what did you think of that take
and I'm like you're talking to me can I
go actually I thought it was actually
goes me to moving on you're like you
know angels are in the back yeah I mean
that that's the great that's the great
stuff you work for and then there's the
the dark you know storming nice when
you're in despair and all these other
things but you really work you know or
that movie premiered at the Palm Springs
Film Festival it opened oh and so we had
a theater of 300 people and I'm sitting
with the stars and and one of them I
grew up as a kid watching his academy or
nominee and I'm like and he turns over
after the movie and he grabs my arm II
says great job mark and I'm like was she
talking to him oh yeah I wrote this
movie and then we get up and we do the
QA and someone asks the the star the
lead they said you know in that one
scene I love what you said your sign was
so amazing and you know an actor could
have went thank you very much you know
and and the star of the movie said well
you know people always say this to
actors what they say is genius he said
but without the writer and he put his
arm around me and he pulled me close he
said there would be nothing to say and
there was another like huh you know so
you have these these these high of highs
but it's not always that sure but but in
that that sounds like it's worth doing
so the others yeah the hard work and
stuff and you want to get to that point
where you're on the set and you're an
equal collaborator not just a fanboy
going oh my gosh oh yeah I wrote this
you're right you know and then even more
when I've had relationships with the
director who said I want you on the set
just as a good luck piece because we
start making changes I want somebody to
go home oh oh you know
going on in the set and people forget
and things fall through the cracks well
the writer is gonna be go hey hey you
know that line you might not want to cut
it you know because it's gonna change
things
so that's but also you don't want to be
they don't want writers on the set
because they are changing things you
want to be the you know grumbling and
say you know walking around angry you're
like how could you be angry you're
eating seared ahi at the craft service
and you're beat got paid and these
wonderful actors are elevating your
material I mean you know sounds good to
me sounds nice to me yeah what if you
what's day one of a rewrite like for
someone else's work so they've given you
notes this is what the person gave us
the other writer get just what's wrong
it's the same you say it it's different
than my own I guess then it is is this
the same process then yeah it's just
it's it's chipping away you know my own
rewrites is based upon notes of people
that I trust like like saying a spec I
would give it to my circle of writer
friends who would give me notes I say
mmm yeah and then okay and then go about
the rewrite but it's it's similar to
when you know just check off the
checklist and say okay and and get that
draft done and and push that push push
each draft closer to the the final
realization of a production draft do you
know which is I mean obviously your spec
is a spec it's not a production but I
mean in a rewrite my job is to push that
as quick as I can to get these changes
made and not hold up everything and
you're doing these changes in in numeric
order in terms of the script page yeah I
mean they're specific which I love other
times I've had broad strokes like well
you know which I put in the book some of
the notes the the emotional highs have
to be higher and the lowers have to be
lower what what does that mean and then
they go okay good luck seeing awake and
you're like I don't know what you're
talking about
wait you know and then if you come back
and ask too many questions or like why
don't we hire you again you know you
don't know what you're doing yes I do
you don't know what you're doing you
know not all producers know how to talk
to writers properly you think they do so
and the really good ones do where they
like really get in there because some of
them are writers as well but the ones
that just paint a broad stroke and then
say see you later and they're busy with
their other projects and you're you have
to learn how to filter that and go with
the emotional highs and lows what what
page what character I don't understand
and they go you don't understand okay
and they pull the chute and you're walk
you're gone you know this is leaving Las
Vegas low yeah yeah re Poppins high yeah
exactly it's like what what do we what
are we doing so but the one the page
specific notes are which then become
scene specific notes once there's the
scene numbers you know happen there like
in this scene XY and Z and you're okay
Bob and this dialogue here blah you know
and so you just go in and do it change
change and change you know and turn that
draft in and hope that's closer and
closer and closer what you don't want is
to be farther and farther away that's
when you bring somebody else in
you